mais revêt des larmes de joie et de
soulagement
colette bana ne peut cacher son émotion
après plus de 20 ans d'attentes
sa maison a été entièrement refaite un
f3 de 60 m² une demeure simple à l'image
de ses propriétaires elle a coûté
environ 70000 euros et des heures de
travail et d'investissement de toute une
équipe
en clair c'est une autre vie à nouveau
départ
là je pense que je serai mieux parce que
ça à gien quand on a des ennuis quand on
a eu en à peine bonne santé et loyers
mais ça ira mieux et en plus je suis
chrétienne alors ça fait du renfort et
je vous donne ma bénédiction à vous tous
parce que vraiment j'ai souffert une
souffrance dans un habitat insalubre
habitat indigne dans lequel colette bana
a vécu pendant de longues années
cette maison elle a hérité de son oncle
décédé à son retour de nouvelle
calédonie un héritage lourd parce que la
nouvelle propriétaire n'avait aucun
moyen de la rénover a pas de toilettes
[Musique]
l'étoile et dix collègues bana et son
fils se sont battus ont frappé à toutes
les portes sans succès jusqu'à leur
recontre salutaire avec cette équipe
dirigée par nathalie loving que les bana
a pu dès lors profiter de la
défiscalisation solidaire et sociale et
c'est l'une des dernières car le
dispositif est supprimée depuis le 24
septembre 2018
des gens qui ont un peu plus de revenus
permettait via la défiscalisation de
rentrer dans un dispositif des aides à
la réhabilitation de logements on a un
très bel exemple dont des cabinets de
défiscalisation
prenez en main ces dossiers et
permettait à des gens qui ment pas de
moyens de pouvoir réhabiliter les
logements
on ne peut pas souhaiter mieux comme
dispositif ce qu'on a fait pour ses 550
familles on aurait pu continuer à le
faire et le faire et continue à le faire
fort autant de familles
sinon plus le combat il est avec
aujourd'hui je dirais des politiques
enfin l'administration fiscale qui qui
ne
veut pas de ce type de dispositif
dispositif remplacé désormais par le
club le programme de logement outre-mer
il sera présenté aux élus dans quelques
jours